[Music]
it's an increasingly common sight in
hospitals around the world a nurse
measures our height weight blood
pressure and attaches a glowing plastic
clip to our finger suddenly a digital
screen reads out the oxygen level in our
bloodstream how did that happen
how can a plastic clip learn something
about our blood without a blood sample
here's the trick
our bodies are translucent meaning they
don't completely block and reflect light
rather they allow sunlight to actually
pass through our skin muscles and blood
vessels don't believe it hold a
flashlight to your thumb light it turns
out can help probe the insides of our
bodies consider that medical finger clip
it's called a pulse oximeter when you
inhale your lungs transfer oxygen into
hemoglobin molecules and the pulse
oximeter measures the ratio of
oxygenated to oxygen free hemoglobin it
does this by using a tiny red LED light
on one side of the finger clip and a
small light detector on the other when
the LED shines into your finger oxygen
free hemoglobin in your blood vessels
absorbs the red light more strongly than
it's oxygenated counterpart so the
amount of light that makes it out the
other side
depends on the concentration ratio of
the two types of hemoglobin but any two
patients will have different sized blood
vessels in their fingers for one patient
a saturation reading of 95% corresponds
to a healthy oxygen level but for
another with smaller arteries the same
reading could dangerously misrepresent
the actual oxygen level this can be
accounted for with a second infrared
wavelength LED light comes in a vast
spectrum of wavelengths an infrared
light lies just beyond the visible
colors all molecules including
hemoglobin absorb light at different
efficiencies across this spectrum so
contrasting the absorbance of red to
infrared light provides a chemical
fingerprint to eliminate the blood
vessels
effect today an emerging medical sensor
industry is exploring all new degrees of
precision chemical fingerprinting using
tiny light manipulating devices no
larger than a tenth of a millimeter this
microscopic technology called integrated
photonics is made from wires of silicon
that guide light like water in a pipe to
redirect reshape even temporarily trap
it a ring resonator device which is a
circular wire of silicon is a light
trapper that enhances chemical
fingerprinting when placed close to a
silicon wire a ring siphons off and
temporarily stores only certain waves of
light those whose periodic wavelength
fits a whole number of times along the
ring circumference it's the same effect
at work when we pluck guitar strings
only certain vibrating patterns dominate
a string of a particular length to give
a fundamental note and its overtones
ring resonators were originally designed
to efficiently route different
wavelengths of light
each a channel of digital data in fiber
optics communication networks but
someday this kind of data traffic
routing may be adapted for miniature
chemical fingerprinting labs on chips
the size of a penny these future labs on
a chip may easily rapidly and
non-invasively detect a host of
illnesses by analyzing human saliva or
sweat in a doctor's office or the
convenience of our homes human saliva in
particular mirrors the composition of
our body's proteins and hormones and can
give early warning signals for certain
cancers and infectious and autoimmune
diseases to accurately identify an
illness labs on a chip may rely on
several methods including chemical
fingerprinting to sift through the large
mix of trace substances in a sample of
spit various biomolecules in saliva
absorb light at the same wavelength but
each has a distinct chemical fingerprint
in a lab on a chip after the light
passes through a saliva sample a host of
fine tuned rings may each siphon off a
slightly different wavelength of light
and send it to a partner light detector
together this bank of detectors will
resolve the cumulative chemical
fingerprint of the sample from this
information a tiny on chip computer
containing a library of chemical
fingerprints for different molecules may
figure out their relative concentrations
and help diagnose a specific illness
from globetrotting communications to
labs on a chip humankind has repurposed
light to both carry and extract
information its ability to illuminate
continues to astonish us with new
discoveries curious how a hidden network
of light and glass make the internet
work check out this video
[Music]